the european union hosts the group of
seven major
industrial powers in brussels for talks
on the conflict in ukraine
the world economy energy security
climate change
and development the meeting had been
scheduled to take place in sochi russia
in g8 format but the leaders decided in
march to meet without moscow
given its annexation of ukraine's crimea
region
ukraine will top the agenda as the
leaders evaluated a working
dinner the latest developments and what
action might be taken in response to
them
other international issues could also be
raised including syria
libya iran afghanistan north korea
or the middle east during their first
working session
the leaders will turn to the global
economy with talks likely to focus on
trade
and ways to sustain economic growth and
combat unemployment
in light of the ukraine crisis and the
country's role as a transit route for
russian gas
energy security will also be discussed
notably the diversification of routes
and suppliers
clean and low carbon technologies are on
the table too
as the powers seek to cut greenhouse gas
emissions and fight climate change
a final working lunch will be devoted to
development issues
taking stock of previous g7 commitments
and looking at the post 2015 agenda
to complete unfinished parts of the
millennium development goals